[MUSIC PLAYING]
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming to
this session of IoT solution
on Google Cloud.
I am Indranil Chakraborty,
I'm a product guy
at Google Cloud working on IoT.
What we're going to cover
today is three things.
One is how do we
think about security
when it comes to building
IoT solution on Cloud?
Second, how do we handle
scale when we think
about IoT solution on Cloud?
And finally, how do we
get actionable insight
for when we build IoT solution?
We'll also have a demo at the
end where one of our partner
has built a pretty
interesting solution for IoT
on Google Cloud.
Let's get started.
What is IoT?
If you Google
internet of things,
one of the first simple
definition that you see
is interconnect via internet
of computing devices embedded
in everyday things.
Essentially, everyday
things interconnected
via the internet.
Hence, internet of things.
And one of the main application
is the first application
you see of internet
of things is at home.
When you think about
Nest thermostat,
you don't have to turn
on your thermostat,
or you don't have to
turn off your thermostat
when you leave the home.
The Nest thermostat
has a sensor.
It knows when you come
inside your house,
and it turns on the heater
to a set temperature.
Google Home can also interact
with your Nest thermostat.
It can even turn on
or off your light.
In fact, you can
use Nest thermostat
to turn off the light
when you leave the home.
So simple everyday
things interacting
with each other via the internet
to create simple magic at home.
And when you think about
internet of things,
the application of
IoT is much broader
outside the context of home.
Let's take example
the parking spaces.
It is estimated that there
are around 800 million parking
spaces in the United States.
San Francisco city alone
has close to half a million
public parking spaces,
but it's still really hard
to find parking in this area.
In fact the San
Francisco city has
done an interesting
experiment with SF Park where
they have embittered
small sensors
in a number of public
spaces which can accurately
detect whether a parking
space is occupied or not.
And this information is sent
to Cloud via the internet.
And so imagine if
you are driving
to meet your friend
at a restaurant,
your car knows exactly where
to find a parking space
because your car is interfacing
via internet with all
the parking space which in
turn is sending real time
update about the availability
of parking space to your car.
Again, everyday
things interacting
with each other via internet
to really make our life easier.
It will also be
nice if while you
are with your
friend at the cafe,
you get an alert about as the
meter is running expiring,
and so you can pay or extend the
meter right from on your phone.
We also seeing a lot of
interesting application
in the industrial
space, as well.
In fact, we have
partners and customers
who are working with
manufacturing industries
where they're able
to remotely monitor
a lot of their machines
across multiple factories.
You see, many of these machines
already collect a lot of data,
even today.
But unfortunately, they're
not able to use it.
Less than 10% of all the
data is actually put to use.
So imagine if all these
machines are connected
over the internet, and as
an Enterprise customer,
or as a factory owner, you
can monitor all your machines
remotely across
different regions,
or even across the globe.
So we see that there's
a lot of applications
of internet of things when it
comes to industrial segment,
as well.
In fact, at Google, we think
internet of things or IoT,
as we call it, is at
a point of inflection.
Depending on the analyst
report you look into,
it is estimated that
by 2020 you will
have anywhere from 20
billion to 40 billion devices
connected to internet.
Now, each of these small devices
might send a few bytes of data
every second.
But when you look at
it in a cumulative way,
the overall amount
of data of which
these devices will generate
is going to be massive.
And so it creates three
challenges for developers,
for partners, when they
start thinking about building
IoT solution on Cloud.
One is security.
And the question
about security is,
how do we make sure that
none of the devices which
are out on the field
connected is compromised?
The recent Dyn attack
is a staunch reminder
that there is a lot of
vulnerability out there.
And how do we make sure that
the data which these devices are
generating is secured not just
when it's stored in the Cloud,
but also during transit as
it's transiting from the device
to the Cloud?
And the second
challenge is scale.
When you have so many millions
or billions of devices,
how do you make sure
that all those devices
is running the same version of
operating system, same version
of firmware, has the
same security patch
so it's very hard to compromise?
And then how do you make sure
that the torrent of data which
would be generated
by so many devices
can be easily handled by
your application on the Cloud
or on-prem?
And finally, insights.
Well, you can have a torrent
of data from all these devices,
but what do you
do with this data?
How do you tease out really
interesting, actionable insight
from the data, which you can
then apply on your application
or for your business case?
At Google, we have
been thinking hard
about these challenges
for a number of years.
And in fact, when it comes
to massive amount of data
processing, ingesting,
and then analyzing,
we've been working
on big data problems
for over a decade
in Google Cloud.
So we have Pub/Sub, Data
Flow Bigtable, Cloud Email,
to name a few of the services
which can operate at scale
and handle massive
amount of data,
which I will talk more about.
When it comes to
internet of things,
we not only think in
the context of Cloud
for security,
scale, and insight,
but we also think about how do
we have the same at the Edge
as well?
And so it is my pleasure to
invite Venkat Rapaka, who
is director of
product manager who
leads IoT platform
on Google to talk
about how we think about Edge
devices and Android things.
Venkat.
VENKAT RAPAKA: Thanks, Indranil.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Venkat Rapaka, as
Indranil mentioned.
I want to talk a
little bit today
about how the notions of scale
security and insight, obviously
they're as important on the
Edge as on the Cloud side,
and I'm excited to
talk about our latest
offering in this space that
should be able to deliver all
of this at the Edge as well.
I'll talk about Android things.
Let me first talk
about what it is.
It is Android,
essentially, right?
Android is one of the most
popular operating systems
out there today.
But it's Android, but
purpose built for IoT.
Think about the internet
of things devices,
there's some pretty interesting
characteristics to them.
A majority of them
don't have a display.
When they do have a display,
it depicts purpose devices
typically.
There is no user-installable
applications, right?
There's no notion
of the use that
interacting with it to install
new capabilities on the device.
So what we did is we
removed a number of things
that we didn't think were
essential in the IoT space.
Things like the applications
that are Android
comes with,
notification support,
and a bunch of things
that are for UI, similarly
to render a UI with
installable applications.
And instead replace it
with things that are,
I think, very relevant for IoT.
Like peripheral support
is a good example.
So you can think of the
right type of sensors
that people will be
building into these devices.
Actuators if you want to
actually operate equipment.
So we added back
some other things
that we think are very
important to the IoT space,
but in the process
we shrunk roughly
the footprint of Android
to about half the size.
Which basically
means that this is
going to be extensible
to a lot more devices.
Still, we're talking
about, to be very clear,
SoC class devices.
These are devices that typically
run something like Linux,
and they tend to be
line powered devices.
But these are the types of
devices that you usually
expect to see at the
edge of the network,
and that run with a lot
of intelligence on it.
So I'll talk about Android
things a little bit more
like, it's an interim solution,
the multiple elements to it.
So I talked about the
operating system a little bit.
It's based on
Android, it's secure.
Android comes with
monthly security updates.
We are committing to multiple
years of monthly security
updates here.
It's, of course, updateable.
I talked about removing a
number of things from Android,
but the thing that preserved is
a majority of the Android APIs.
All the APIs that are delivering
for these types of devices
are all preserved.
And what that means is
we get all the Android
APIs, and the
developer environment
and the test tools that
are currently available,
but also a million Android
app developers that exist
today could all become IoT
device if they so choose.
So if you're out there and
you want to build a device,
you no longer need
deep OS expertise.
You don't need
people who understand
firmware, and kernel,
and OS level security.
You should be able to
take Android things
and be able to
build a device just
by building an Android app
that can run on top of Android.
The other thing
that we're doing is
we're including APIs to
enable these devices to be
managed at scale.
So if you have
hundreds or thousands
of these devices in
your installation,
you should be able to use a
standard off the shelf console
and be able to manage
all of these devices.
But the OS is only
a part of what it
takes to build a great device.
There's hardware, right?
And building hardware is
incredibly complicated
for a lot of people.
How do you pick the
components, how do
you assemble them all together?
And to do that, we are
working very closely
with a number of major
industry players,
and we're building with
them pre-certified boards.
And these boards
come with compute,
they come with
connectivity and storage.
So what this does is it takes
both a lot of the complexity,
and the guesswork,
and the risk that it
takes to build a great device,
but also it takes out the time
to market.
So these certified
boards, they guarantee
to run Android things.
They get regular
updates every month,
and they get you
started out of the gate
without having to know a lot
about how to build a device.
And again, our attempt with
these and with our partners
is that if you're
trying to prototype,
you should be able to
buy one of these things,
not have to commit to
10,000 of them just
to get to some
minimum order quantity
to get scale efficiency.
So the cost will scale
linearly, as well.
So these are all the ways we're
trying to take the friction out
of the ability to
build a great device.
The third thing that's
really interesting
is that as we're
building this OS,
we're also looking at
all the types of services
that we can include
in a turnkey fashion
to make it easy to build a great
product at the end of the day.
So a few examples up here.
The first symbol that
you see is, of course,
the Google Cloud platform.
So if you're building
a device that
requires data to be connected,
like sent back to a cloud,
you should be able
to use Google Cloud
platform in a seamless way.
The second one is TensorFlow.
To be able to do on-device
intelligence, of course.
Location services,
location services
come for free with Android.
The fourth one
symbolizes connectivity.
Of course, there's Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth as you would expect,
but also because it's
based on Android,
you get cellular connectivity
capability as well.
And this is, of course,
one of the most commonly
used operating systems by all
the carriers in the world.
So to be able to build now an
LTE capable device suddenly
becomes much more accessible
to people using something
like Android Things.
And over time, we intend
to support additional types
of connectivity matters
like thread, for example,
for local low power
connectivity with devices
that are out there that are
battery powered, for example.
So this is the sum total of
what makes Android Things what
it is, which is an end to
end solution for people
to be able to build
a great device.
Let me talk about what
this starts to enable.
And I'll pick one
specific example
to talk about, a smart camera.
So imagine you're trying to
build something like a Nest
cam, it's a security camera.
You should be able to
pick from among options
of certified hardware.
Something that meets your
price and your performance
characteristics of the
device you want to build.
Should be able to
get one of those.
download Android Things
so you have a secure operating
system to go with it.
But it's a camera
you're building,
there's a video feed
coming out, and you
might want to save it
somewhere on the Cloud.
Or you might want
to be able to access
it using either a browser
or a mobile device.
And I mentioned, of course,
the Google Cloud Platform
and, it's built right in.
But also bandwidth is expensive.
And if you have installation
of these devices,
and you don't want to be
pumping data out all the time.
You want to be able
to do something
intelligent on the device
itself to make sure
that you only send data up to
the Cloud when you want to.
And for that we have
TensorFlow, right?
So as an example, you
should be able to look
at what the camera is
seeing on the device itself
and decide, what is it
that I'm looking at?
Is it a cat running
through the yard,
or is it a person walking up?
And is it a person
that I trust and know,
or is it someone
that I don't know,
and therefore I'm
going to alert?
So suddenly you have
the variety of options,
starting all the way
from doing nothing,
log it but don't wake
somebody up, wake somebody up.
So you suddenly start
to do all of that
locally without having
to send a ton of data
out into the cloud to do that.
And I talked about one specific
example of a security camera,
but the thing that
makes this interesting
is this should be the
same kind of a process.
Just by learning a
different TensorFlow model,
suddenly you have
a traffic camera
that can figure out the license
plate number on device itself.
And take a photo of somebody
who violates a red light
and then sends that photo out.
You can imagine this camera
sitting inside a building
and doing occupancy
detection and saying,
this is the number
of people who use
this space at this
time of the day,
and only send those
heuristics up, as opposed
to actually sending
the full data
feed to have to be
processed on the cloud.
But all of a sudden,
you can imagine
building a device like this.
And just by what
you download to it,
it suddenly changes
in characteristics
and what it can do.
I'm going to turn this
around now and start
talking about how as
a device developer
you can build this very easily.
But I'm going to turn
this around and say,
let's imagine that
you are an enterprise,
and you have 1,000 of
these cameras sitting
all around your
buildings worldwide,
and you want to do
premise monitoring.
I talked about the
management at scale.
So you should be able to look
at all of these cameras on one
console, and you should
be able to update
the model that you use on it
to maybe do facial recognition.
Maybe your employee
database changes every day,
because somebody new
joins, somebody left.
Maybe you want to download
that new database down
to each of these cameras
so they can do detection
at the edge itself for you.
These are all possible from
a console with one click.
And the other cool thing is,
you might have cameras also
running Android Things
inside your building doing
your occupancy detection,
and your cameras that
are doing premise monitoring.
Now they're all based
on Android Things.
You should be able to use
the same console to look
at all of them in one spot,
which is exactly how we're
trying to take the friction
out of an enterprise with all
the management overhead
you would expect.
So a lot more happening.
We're right now in developer
preview with Android Things.
Over the next few
months, we're going
to have multiple developer
preview releases coming out.
Towards the early part of
the second half of this year,
we're going to go into
commercial availability.
So please stay tuned,
you'll find more information
at the tooling subdev.
Thank you again.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Thank you, Venkat.
So as Venkat mentioned,
with Android Things,
you can really build a device
application which is secured,
which can scale, and you can
use TensorFlow to get insights
on the edge itself.
Now let's talk about
Cloud, and how do we
handle security scale and
insight within Google Cloud?
There are a number of services
which I've listed here.
I'm going to talk about a
couple of key services which
can really help in building
a secure, scalable,
and insightful application
when it comes to IoT.
First, let's talk
about security.
On Google Cloud, every data
by default is encrypted.
It's encrypted at
rest as well as it's
encrypted when in transit.
Now, we understand
that there could
be a couple of very specific
customer client needs, or user
needs, because of which you
would need multiple option
depending on the
level of protection
that the customer or you
are more comfortable with.
So we do offer a wide
spectrum of options
when it comes to security.
The first, as I
mentioned, is encryption
by default. In which case you
are using Google Cloud scale
and velocity and our
key management system
without needing to
implement any of your own.
In this case, you would be
using the same key management
system which is
used by other Google
products such as Apps, Google
Maps, Search, and others.
And so you get the
benefit of Google scale
and infrastructure.
At the same time, you get
a high degree of security
when it comes to IoT data.
For reasons if you do not
choose to trust with us for data
key management, we
do offer customer
supplied encryption keys.
If you would like to
maintain your keys
and manage your
keys on-prem, you
could do that with this option.
In this option, you will
have full control on creation
and management of keys, and
Google will use those keys only
at the time of
encryption, but will not
retain it on the Cloud.
You will get the
security, but the user
will have to make sure that
the keys are provisioned
and managed on-prem.
We are also working with
customers and partners,
and we realized that we need to
offer a middle ground, as well.
If you don't trust us with
the key management system,
but you don't want
to have full control,
then we have a middle ground
which is called the Cloud Key
Management System.
In this case, you have full
control for key creation,
deletion, rotation, revocation.
But the entire key
management system
is done on Google
Cloud infrastructure.
So you get the benefit of Google
Cloud, the velocity of Google
Cloud infrastructure,
but you have
full control of how you want
to manage your own keys.
So again, essentially
we offer a high degree
of security on Cloud with the
option which meets your needs
and is flexible, as well.
So that's how we
look at security,
which is high security,
but at the same time
we do give you options to
meet your own customer or user
goals.
When it comes to scale,
as I mentioned before,
we have been working on
this for quite a long time.
And if you take the example
of the parking space,
individual sensors might be
sending small trickle of data.
But in aggregate,
when you think about
even if you have 10 million
more parking spaces in US which
are all connected with
sensors to indicate
whether the space
is occupied or not,
that's a huge volume of data.
Even if those sensors
are sending the data
over a few seconds
or a few minutes.
So you need a service which
can ingest this massive scale
of data, and then
route this data
to different services for
processing and analysis.
And Cloud Pub/Sub is a
great service for that.
What it essentially
does is it has
a topic which all its devices
can publish do, either directly
or via gateway.
And you can have other services
to subscribe to these topics
to ingest to consume the data.
The three key things which
is unique to Cloud Pub/Sub.
Number one is the durable
message persistence.
What does it mean?
So if you think about these
small constrained devices,
they don't have
enough compute power
to try to resend the data when
it's not getting an ack back
from the ingestion service.
You want to be able
to send the data out
without much challenge, and
without much computing power.
So Cloud pops up, makes
sure that the data is stored
and we didn't send an ack
back until the published
from the device is consumed.
So that's one key advantage.
A second is even though
your devices might
be globally
distributed, you would
want to be able to consume
it from a central location
so you can remotely
monitor all those devices.
So Cloud Pub/Sub is
a global service.
And you don't have to think
about creating separate shards,
or different regions.
You just publish your devices
to one topic, and it handles it,
and it scales.
In fact, Pub/Sub scales
internally to the extent
that whether it is a couple
of thousands of messages
or a couple of millions, it
just scales automatically.
When it comes to
internet of things,
there are certain
unpredictability
in terms of load.
So sometimes the devices
might be sending few data,
and all of a sudden if there
is in real world there's
increasing load, it might
be sending a massive amount
of data for ingestion.
And Cloud Pub/Sub
scales automatically
without you needing to provision
or add any new infrastructure.
In fact, it can handle anywhere
from a few thousand messages
to millions of messages per
second in a matter of minutes
without you needing
to do anything.
So that's great about Pub/Sub.
Another thing it
does well it is it
separates the
downstream application
from the upstream
deployment of your devices.
So you can continue to
make changes or build
new application which consumes
the data sent by your devices,
or you can send it to a
different e-tail pipeline,
you can have data flow or
cloud function consume it.
And you can keep making changes
without needing to change
your device deployment.
So it creates an abstraction
between your upstream device
deployed and your
downstream application.
So it allows you to
iterate on your application
at a much faster speed.
And finally, it also
allows you to connect
to some of the powerful
real time services
we have, such as Cloud
Dataflow and Cloud Function,
which I will just talk about.
So now that you've ingested
this massive amount of data
at scale, in case of
IoT application, most
of the typical
time you would want
to get some real time insights.
Real time information.
If you think about the
parking lot example,
you would want to know real
time how many spaces are
available near Moscone
Center, or how many spaces are
available near a park
public garage space nearby.
So that as you are
driving in, your car
knows exactly which
parking garage to get into.
And so Dataflow
has the mechanism
where it can real time
process streams of data.
You can create windows
to define boundaries
and then it can aggregate,
you can run some aggregation
or average, or run other
computation, as well.
So Dataflow can be used
for a couple of things
when you get streams
of data from devices.
One is, as you get data from
different devices in the field,
the data format
could be different.
And what you would want to do
before you process or analyze
the data is you would
want to standardize
the format across this
different class of devices.
And so you could use
that with Dataflow,
where you can create
a real time job
to do format translation
for data coming
across different devices.
Second is in real time,
it can create average.
You can compute
an average, or you
can do different transformation
on the data itself.
In our simple example
for parking space,
one could compute
average number of spaces
available in a parking garage
or in the whole region,
and then you can use that to
build some demand prediction,
or even do pricing based
on demand, as well.
And finally,
Dataflow can also be
used to not just
work on the data
which you're receiving from
the internet of things,
you can also add data
from other services.
So you can get weather data,
you can get some traffic data,
and combine all this information
to do more rich analysis
real time.
That's the power
of data flow, which
we think is great to
build IoT application.
Once you process the data,
you want a simple way
of moving the data or
storing the data so
that you can do subsequent
analysis on that data.
And we recently announced
Dataflow Templates, which
is great for easy data movement
between Pub/Sub to other cloud
services, such as Bigtable
or BigQuery for storage,
DCS for storage, or
even for a Cloud ML.
The unique advantage
of Dataflow Template
is that as a developer, you can
create your own environment.
You can create a template to
connect data from Pub/Sub to,
let's say, BigQuery
in this example.
Compile it, and
then you save it.
And then a non
developer operation user
doesn't have to compile it.
All they do is they'll open
the Google Cloud console
as it's shown here, they
will select the template
which just pops up to BigQuery.
It's parametrized.
So they will enter the
topic of the Pub/Sub
on which the data from
these devices are published.
They will select
the table BigQuery,
and then just run the job.
And in the background,
the template automatically
spins up a job and
transfers your data
as it comes in to the BigQuery
table which you mentioned.
So really easy, and it helps you
not only for storage, but also
to scale.
So as a developer you
create templates once,
and the operations
folks can then
execute on those run
jobs on this template
without needing to
compile every time.
You can also use templates
for creating simple rules.
So as a developer,
you can create
a rule that says every time
the number of parking space
goes below 10 in
a public garage,
I want to send an
alert, or I want
to send SMS message to
to these mobile phones.
You can also create
an alert where
you say every time
something happens,
I want to send a
message to datastore.
All of that can be
done using Templates.
As a developer, you create,
you build the template,
you code it, and you save it.
And not non-developer
users can just
execute the job without
needing to compile every time.
So that works great for the
purpose of scale, as well.
Now once you've analyzed
the data at real time,
you have ingested the
data, you've analyzed it,
there are a number of options to
store the data on Google Cloud.
You can use Google
Cloud Storage if you
don't care about the structure.
You can use Cloud Datastore if
you have key value pair format
and the data is more structured.
You can even use Cloud
SQL for that matter.
But there's one service
which I will highlight
which applies very
well for the IoT use
case, which is Bigtable.
If you think about the
public parking example,
there are use cases where the
public garage, the garage owner
might want to do some demand
analysis to really understand
what are some of the
peak times when I
see a peak demand for parking?
And he or she can also use it
to do predictive pricing based
on demand.
Best way to do that is to
do time series analysis
on the data stream, which the
parking garage and I might
be collecting from all
the parking spaces.
And this is where
Bigtable shines.
Because Bigtable
scales horizontally.
Whether you're talking about
few thousands of writes
per second or millions of writes
per second, Bigtable scales
internally.
And it's great for
time series analysis,
because it's a column
based, NoSQL database.
The challenge with
Bigtable is you
have to be very careful in
how you design the schema when
you're thinking about
time series analysis.
But what's great is we
have open TSDB, which
is an open source
we strongly support.
And it abstracts a time
series schema on Bigtable.
So if you want to do time series
analysis on a series of data
coming from your IoT devices,
and your IoT solution requires
predictive processing, you
can use open TSDB on Bigtable,
and you should be up and
running and designing the time
series in a matter of no time.
Now you've ingested
the data, you've
processed data real time,
you stored the data, as well.
There's an aspect of
reporting and visualization
which is also important
when you think
about building IoT solution.
We do have two services
which can help you
build reports and dashboards.
There's data and Data Studio
what Datalab is great for, more
sophisticated analysis.
If you want to get the data,
and if you have statisticians
with PhD's who would really want
to go deeper into the data use
R to create some regression
model, Datalab great.
It has a notebook interface,
it leverages existing Jupiter
modules, and is suitable for
any data science and houses,
or even building machine
learning models as well.
It is closely integrated
with BigQuery and Cloud ML,
so it makes it really easy
for you to take that data
and then build a cloud ML model
for more sophisticated analysis
down the road.
Data Studio, on the
other hand, is primarily
targeted for business analysts.
So if you want to create
a simple dashboard where
you want to show all your
fleet or truck movements
on a Google map,
Data Studio is great.
And then you can use that to
constantly monitor and generate
report on an ongoing basis.
It doesn't require any
technical expertise.
You can drag, drop BigQuery
table or Excel sheet,
or some other source, even
CSVs, onto Data Studio.
And you can create some
really enriched dashboard
for your reporting purposes.
So Datalab and Data Studio is
great for generating reports
to really tease out actionable
insights from the data
after you've processed
and stored it.
So I talked about the
different processes.
I'm sure you would want
to see all this in action.
So I'm going invite
Jose Ugia, who's
going to give a demo of
a smart fleet which they
have built on Google Cloud.
Jose.
JOSE UGIA: Thank, Indranil.
So every time I see the
slide that Indranil just
showed about the respected
growth of the IoT devices
in the industry,
then I always get
to this profound,
yet simple thought.
And that is that we'll
be surrounded by them.
And because of that, in tech
we have gotten things wrong
a few times, especially
when it comes to security,
when it comes to scalability,
when it comes to reliability.
And I think this
time what we can do
is try to learn from
the previous mistakes.
Come up with a set of
practices in all those things.
So by the time this happens,
we are ready to do that.
And that's something that in our
company we have really present,
and we love to keep it that
way for the months to come.
So at Noa, what we
do is, our vision
is to transform the
way we understand
and utilize urban
transportation.
And we do this in two main ways.
We want to do that in
two main verticals.
Which are making transportation
more convenient to you
within urban fleets--
that's commuters, that students,
that in police of campuses.
We want to make
it easier to find
actual means of
transportation to move around.
But the most important
part, and this
is where we are putting
most of our efforts,
is on reducing the operational
costs of managing those fleets.
Especially when it comes
to a large number of them.
So there are things
involved that
grow with the number
of devices linearly.
And what we want
through automation
and add in features that
provide insights and knowledge,
we want to reduce this cost.
And so one of the companies
that we work with is Google.
This is why we have
this bike over there.
This bike has
something here which
we call the donut, which
is our hardware device that
helps us sense.
So next time you go
to the Google campus
and you think about taking
one of those bicycles
as a souvenir, you
may think twice,
because we are
tracking those things.
So if we can switch
quickly to the wall,
that sounds very powerful.
Switch to the walls.
This is how the
device looks like.
So as you can see, it's
a small rounded element
with machinery inside.
And you may imagine
why we call it donut,
that's obvious reasons.
And it has this shape because
it goes next to the wheel.
So the interesting thing
is that you can simply
take that wheel out, replace it
with one that has this device,
and then boom, you're connected.
As easy as that.
What this device
senses is things
like humidity, temperature, gas,
or pollution related particle.
And we also have
antennas to connect
to the cellular network.
We know the location
of the device,
because we have GPS
antennas as well.
All together to provide us with
the information that we need.
And if we can go back
to the slides please,
the information that we
need to help these operators
make those decisions that
make them reduce costs.
There is already cost reduction.
But in some cases,
this means viability.
It may mean the
difference between having
a program or not.
So as you may have heard, there
are a few cities in the US
in which this has really
been a huge struggle.
In which the public systems
cannot sustain those programs
anymore because
of their pricing.
So in some cases that will
mean having them or not.
And this is what really
makes us excited about it.
Before we jump into matter,
we have been running on Google
for a few months now.
And I thought it was worth
sharing some of the stats
that we have gathered with you.
Googlers, they seem
to be healthy people.
They cycle the world every
month with their bicycles.
Everyone knows the diameter of
our lovely blue planet, right?
So that's a lot of distance.
And we only have a subset
of the devices equipped,
we don't have all of them.
So that's something
that came as a surprise,
not because we thought that
everyone was sedentary,
but because we thought the
activity was going to be lower.
It was really great to see that.
We have more than 100,000 trips
every three months at Google,
and there might be
something going on at night.
Because we have seen that
after 8 PM And before 6 AM,
there are 1,000
trips every month.
So not sure if we
will find out or not,
but there's some kind of
secret project or fund
that happens really late at
night within the Google campus.
But how do we leverage
Google products?
And why this is
really useful for us.
We base our data
pipeline from our devices
in two main principles.
One of them is real time.
We need to leave in real time
because there are many things
that depend on this.
Like security, like
infrastructure,
like availability, like
the month of bicycles.
And we need to know about
those as quickly as possible.
If someone is maybe trying to
steal a bike, any of you maybe,
we need to know but as
quickly as possible.
So we want that to be
milliseconds or seconds.
That's why we
ingest into Pub/Sub.
And once we do that,
we transfer in parallel
to all the different services.
That is Alert, that is location
updates, that is insights,
as well.
The other principle that we
have is that our information
is simple at the
beginning, how we want
to transform that as it comes.
So think of it as
LEGO pieces, right?
By themselves, they may be just
colorful, beautiful pieces,
but they mean almost nothing.
What we do with them,
when we put them together,
when we assemble them, then
we can construct things
like cars, rockets,
houses, buildings, things
that have meaning, right?
So this is what we do
with our information
as soon as it comes,
and we transform it
as it arrives and then send it
to the different services which
are interested.
And that is once
again within the order
of milliseconds or seconds.
This is how it looks
when we translate
what I have said into Google
services, or Google products
from a really high level.
There are two things to
highlight in this slide.
One of them is that we use
MQTT, we have a set of machines
that we use as a gateway to
which our devices communicate.
They ingest.
We use MQTT as a protocol,
and protocol buffers
as a message format.
Just because it's convenient,
we are in the outside,
we're in a hostile
environment with rain,
with cold, with wind, with
reduced cellular connectivity,
with reduced GPS coverage.
And so having the chance to
have a protocol that is meant
thought for that is great,
that's why we use it.
The other one is that if you
see the second part, this spurt
of Pub/Sub plus Data
Flow, this layers which
seem to be repeated, this tax
is what I just mentioned before.
This allows us to, once
we ingest into Pub/Sub
and we process in Data Flow,
then some of those results
will make it into storages,
or into different services
themselves.
Some of those will be
republished into Pub/Sub
so we can keep on transforming
and analyzing that.
And I'll show you a couple of
examples of that in a second.
Lastly we'll love to
touch on something
that has really changed the
way we analyze our information.
We used to spend a lot
of time to find out
how our data was performing.
That is in terms of insights, in
terms of business intelligence,
but also monitoring.
Because we have our
[INAUDIBLE] devices, and we
have data about those.
So we can find out
whether the GPS accuracy
is good or bad, for example.
We take a longer
time, now we leverage
where we make use of BigQuery
query so we can make decisions
much faster.
And sometimes this really
provides for a big difference
in how our product
is being run, and how
to invest the little resources
that we have as a small company
to make the best out of
it for our customers.
If we can switch to the product
demo without further ado,
the theory was great.
But things are much better
than when we show them live.
And so let's all invoke
all the demo gods,
and let's challenge them
right here on the stage.
Can we switch now?
Yeah.
So what you will see
here is just a reflection
of what I just explained.
In this case, I want
to show you two things.
One is right where we are
right now where this device is,
and where one of our
colleagues is cycling.
She must have gone
really far, there she is.
The reason why it's green
is because she's moving.
And this shows a reflection
of the current snapshot.
This is where she
is right now, this
is the battery the
device has, this
is the status of the device.
You saw that I just moved this
device that we have over here.
In a few seconds,
if I don't break it,
it's going to get
green [INAUDIBLE].
So this is just transmitting
from here right now real time.
And you saw that quickly,
we saw it on the system.
But things get more interesting
if we go to the Google Fleet.
Because you just
saw three bicycles.
But if we go in here,
there's plenty more.
This is right now
in Mountain View
after lunchtime, which is one
of the peak times of activity.
So if we get to one of the
most crowded areas in here,
in the cross with the
Shorebird and Charleston,
then we have bicycles moving.
I don't know if
you can see them.
But as we move
through the screen,
they are moving right now.
So this is just
the basic snapshot.
But why do we reaggregate
and process information?
What can we get
out of it, right?
If we go to Trips, which is one
of the most interesting views
for many of our operators,
just with one query
we can see what's the
path of that bicycle.
If we want to learn about what
happened to specific bicycle,
one of the back, or
it may be suffering
any suspicious behavior.
We can come here, now
it's not trackings,
anymore it's not
little messages,
it's not the LEGO pieces.
Now we have that full trip.
So we have the start, the end,
the velocity, the distance.
Things that make it much
easier for us to consume.
And then here we can keep
going back as we can see.
And we'll go through the
history of that bicycle.
Concentrate on the trips
that we are interested in.
Finally, we have seen
trackings, you have seen trips.
This is great.
The interesting part
of this approach
is that we can go from
here into whatever we need.
So for example, once we have
Trips, we do two things.
We run a Data Flow job
to filter them out.
Because you know,
GPS has errors,
so you need to filter that out.
So you need to maybe
go through certain APIs
to make it a bit clearer.
So we do that, but
another thing that we do
is we calculate metrics,
organization-wise.
So what you're seeing
is the aggregate metrics
for distance in Google for
the overall organization.
So there's a time
based serious metric.
And as you can see, as we
change the actual date range,
this is really quick, this
is round trip, by the way.
The servers are in Ireland,
so it's round trip.
You see that's really quick.
But that's not the
important thing.
The important thing is
that this information
is really pre-calculated.
That's why it's quick.
Which means that
our servers don't
have to calculate
it every single time
that we run this query.
Not only that, but also that we
can use all those things which
had already denormalized
and stored in our system,
in our databases, we can use
them then for further jobs.
Like analytics,
machine learning,
and so on and so forth.
And so with that, this is
what I want to show you.
I hope this resembles something
that you may be thinking of,
some project that
you may have already.
And I hope this is good insights
for you for the actual months
to come.
If you want to
find out more, you
can find us under
they're [INAUDIBLE].
There's a little
section on the right
that says something like jobs
you may be interested in.
But other than that,
I want to thank you,
and would love to hand
it back to Indranil.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Thank you, Jose.
So as you saw in Jose's demo,
he used Google Cloud not just
to track real time the
different bicycles,
but he also used it
to do post-analysis,
and even those analyses
were pretty fast, because he
was using BigQuery and others.
And it's interesting that this
whole application can also
be used for urban
transportation,
and even in the case
of parking lot space.
We also do have a demo on the
third floor in the IoT expert
booth.
I would highly encourage that
you guys should check it out.
Essentially what it does is it
shows the simple application
of Pub/Sub, Data Flow, and
is compatible with Android
Things, as well.
So what does demo does, and
as you go, you will find out.
It has a couple of temperature
sensors on Raspberry Pi.
And these thermometer
sensors are
sending temperature
measurement data,
continuously sending
the measurement data,
to Pub/Sub, which
then distributes
the data to Data Flow.
And data flow does
in real time compute
the average temperature.
And then it goes through
different pipeline.
And every time, as the
average temperature
reaches above a
certain threshold,
it fires a Firebase
message to the controller
which turns on the fan.
So it's a very
simple, nifty demo.
But it shows you
the different pieces
in a very simplistic way.
And how you can use Pub/Sub,
Data Flow, Android Things,
and other cloud services
to build your IoT solution
for your specific use case.
We also do have two
other IoT session.
One tomorrow at around 11:00
in the morning at Marriott,
which covers Nest, and how
Nest is using Google Cloud
Platform to build their
thermostat intelligent
application.
And so I think that's
something which
would be really interesting if
you're interested in building
IoT solution.
And then there is
another session
which is on Friday afternoon, at
around 1:20 PM at Moscone West.
And there, we're going to show
how our customers and partners
are building industrial IoT
application using Google Cloud
Platform.
So I think that's something
which will be interesting
for you all, as well.
So to summarize,
what we covered is
how we use Android Things
to make the edge secure,
and how we use Android Things
to manage millions and billions
of devices at scale.
And also you were able to run
TensorFlow to get insights
at the edge itself.
We also talked about
how Google Cloud,
we offer multiple options to
add the same degree of security
so that it can meet your
specific client or user
needs as you're building
out the application.
And I also covered Pub/Sub
Data Flow, and Google Bigtable,
how that can be used to ingest
data at scale, processing it
and analyze it
real time at scale.
And use some of our
dashboarding applications,
such as Data Flow or Data Studio
to get actionable insights.
So we at Google are very
excited with this space.
We are getting started, and
we are working hard not just
for security scale
and insight, we
are also working hard to make
it really simple for developers
and customers to make IoT
applications on Google Cloud.
There's a lot more you'll hear
from us throughout the year,
so stay tuned.
And we're excited, and I hope
you guys are excited to join us
on the journey, as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]